well i mean right off the bat
get as much stuff out on youtube as you
can and see what sticks to the wall
because you know youtube is they're
paying now they got you can get
monetized you get a thousand subscribers
and
however many views because i mean i'll
be honest
that's why i did those lockdown videos
during the the pandemic
i got on every day and just did a four
or five minute rant about
something because one of it
kept me sane kept my brain like working
but two
i'm youtube i was monetized so
it's it's money it's revenue coming in
when we're not on the road
you know are there are there any other
ways we can monetize our comedy
um you could if you get a something
catchy i guess you could do an online
store
there's t-shirts we got masks now i mean
i talked to duval
he he got that t-shirt out there um what
do you say
uh we're in this together but stay the
away from me
is what his t-shirt said uh
he said making i don't want to put his
mouth there but he's making a decent
amount of money off of just that t-shirt
and that wasn't on a comedy special he
just like put it out there on the
internet
and people gravitated to it you know so
there i mean there's
there's ways there's outlets
you